a highly contagious fungal infection
that may not respond to medication could
put hospital and nursing home patients
at risk the CDC says Candida Oris has
been detected in six continents since it
was first identified about a decade ago
there are 715 confirmed or suspected
cases in the US alone Meg Oliver is here
now with how health care teams are
stepping up the fight against the spread
of an infection that they say is
inevitable yikes
that's right good morning to all of you
New York New Jersey and Illinois have
had the largest clusters of Candida Oris
it's especially deadly for people with
compromised immune systems as one
Chicago family learned after their
mother died in February less than a year
ago stephanie spore was celebrating the
engagement of her son Zachary
Nicholas is Zachary's brother you know
it was in fathomable that she wouldn't
make it to the wedding you know it was
in June Stephanie who was 64 when she
died suffered from lupus Nicholas says
the autoimmune disease was under control
but when she started having breathing
problems she was admitted to a Chicago
area hospital within weeks she
contracted Canada Oris and the doctors
asked for a family meeting
and it was four or five of us and 13
doctors and that's when we knew kind of
it was bad it was bad instead of
attending her son's June wedding
stephanie watched him take his vows in a
sterile hospital room that's the one
time she cried after she had found out
that she wasn't going to make it was was
that the wedding a few days later
stephanie died the trumpets have been
sounding for some time that this is a
real problem dr. mark ruff chief of
infectious diseases at Nebraska medicine
says the overuse of antibiotics and
antifungals leaves fewer treatment
options it has the unfortunate capacity
of being very very resistant to some of
our antifungals and it also has a
capacity to contaminate the environment
and persist in the environment so it's
kind of a double whammy in the infection
control
nebraska medicine is at the forefront of
infection control in training it has one
of only nine bio containment units in
the US which has been used to treat
patients quarantined with ebola now it's
playing offense against candida Oris and
other highly contagious germs Candida
auras can quickly spread from room to
room on people clothing and even lunch
trays the Medical Center has enhanced
infection control training and
surveillance to keep it contained we're
doing what's called a seven step
cleaning process when patients who have
been treated for highly infectious
illnesses are discharged the human
housekeepers are followed by a cleaning
robot that zaps germs and what is the UV
light - it's an ultraviolet C light that
pulsates and it removes microorganisms
bacteria off of surfaces should every
Hospital America have one of these they
should they should have several when you
read the headlines that this is a
mysterious and a dangerous
drug-resistant fungus should Americans
be alarmed I think they should be aware
they should be concerned they should be
engaged for the spore family Canada Oris
told their chance to fully comfort
Stephanie in her last days I can't
imagine how it should what she was
feeling at the time like looking at
everybody with gowns and and rubber
gloves the day she passed when they
turned off the machines he said you can
take your gloves off if you want to
touch her it was nice to be able to to
do that dr. Rob told me that family
should ask the hospital about infection
control protocols and most importantly
keep their eyes open to make sure
personnel wash hands each time they
enter the room or touch objects that may
be contaminated he also recommends a
Medicare website called Hospital Compare
that ranks hospital quality Stephanie's
son Nicholas told us at the hospital
that treated her did everything they
could and there's new research out that
tells us what might be causing this
Michelle this is fascinating because for
the first time scientists now say the
global warming may be helping this
fungus spread our bodies 10
the church typically act as a barrier
but this variation has overcome that
barrier because it's adapting to warming
temperatures scary how quickly it can
spread mm-hmm yeah and I can I say that
that cleaning robot that we saw in there
was that never seen anything like that
right yeah that's leading the way they
definitely as that doctor said more
hospitals need those yeah it's
remarkable I will also point out it
looks a bit like r2d2 does all right Meg
thank you very much